ici aucune motorisation ni tracteur ni
silo ou abreuvoir automatique tout se
fait à la main comme autrefois un peu
comme nos grands-parents en fait faisait
ou une nourrissait dès le matin ils
allaient voir leurs animaux et les
nourrisser les abreuver voilà c'est
surtout ça c'était pouvoir recréer en
fait cette ferme d'antan des
grands-parents en fait la ferme au bois
dormant un élevage de volailles c'est
lapins de race local et ancienne près
d'un millier d'animaux et une multitude
d'astuces là une bétonnière pour
mélanger les céréales ici une simple
poubelle domestique on a détourné avec
un système de pipette tout autour ou la
poule va venir donc appuyer dessus ce
qui permet de distribuer à l'infusion de
thym et
décoction donc dedans pour les soigner
Valentin et Sébastien se sont installés
il y a 3 ans l'ancien barman et l'ex
brancardi on construit une ferme à leur
image entre partage et solidarité
les filles
cochon chèvre mouton des animaux
destinés à l'abattoir recueillis par les
deux autres là vous avez coton et Michel
l'idée c'est de sauver quelques animaux
pour leur apporter un refuge une fin de
vie du coup heureuse le couple vend sa
production sur les marchés ou à la ferme
des produits parfois étonnants
pour faire du savon on a besoin de gras
et on a on travaille avec une savonnerie
de saint-mars-la-pileue des partenariats
avec des acteurs locaux comme avec ce
boucher voilà donc ça c'est pour
transformer s'il te plaît ici sont
conçus saucisse crépinette terrine
mousse et rillettes de poulet rôti une
association bénéfique pour chacun c'est
dans l'air du temps et que c'est les
gens sont depuis toujours
aiment bien savoir ce qu'il mange et
d'où ça vient
Sébastien et Valentin vivent chichement
mais qu'importe gagner beaucoup beaucoup
d'argent est-ce que ça a du sens
peut-être pour certains pour nous notre
sens c'est vivre avec nos animaux
partager nos valeurs là on a accueilli
dernièrement quelques groupes et c'est
vrai que c'est continué dans ce sens du
coup et partager des repas et des temps
conviviaux à la ferme prochain
rendez-vous le 2 septembre avec un
marché ouvert